okay
okay here we are finally all right well
welcome to
another episode of science and
technology q a
for kids and others um
we had a bunch of questions saved up
from last week
and maybe we could start with some of
those there's a question from
will here is there a physical principle
that governs moore's law
why is there so much available
computation
okay let me talk a little bit about that
so what is moore's law
moore's law is a empirical
fact um that was originally
suggested by gordon moore who is then
ceo of intel
uh largest manufacturer of
microprocessors in the world
and his uh rule of thumb was i think
it's processor
speed doubles every 18 months i think
that was the
the the claim and that was something
that was said back in the
70s 80s computers were getting faster
computers were getting faster every uh
you know getting doubling in speed with
some considerable
at some considerable rate and it was
sort of an impressive thing
and for a long period of time and i
remember people saying oh my gosh
one day we'll have gigahertz speed
microprocessors what does the speed mean
the speed means every instruction that
gets done by the computer
every machine code instruction that gets
done by the computer
how long does it take well actually more
accurately there's usually a clock
that is one tick of the clock some the
the
an instruction may take one click of the
clock two three
four different instructions take
different amounts of time typically
reading one piece of data from memory
takes
well depends where it is they're
different levels of memory but but the
fastest
will take maybe one clock cycle but
anyway so the question is
how fast is the clock and if you look up
on your computer you know i could look
at my computer here and
sure let's see what is it this is a 2.7
gigahertz computer so that means that um
nearly three billion times a second
there is a
a clock pulse where something can happen
in the computer
so i remember back in the 1990s
people are wondering when are we going
to make it to a gigahertz are we ever
going to make it to a gigahertz
it was things like there were you know
one two megahertz
cpus things like that how can we go
faster how can we go faster
and uh the impressive thing was that
every couple of years
it was like we're pretty much doubling
the speed of processors
and how was that achieved and what's
happened well
the bad news is the last probably 10
years
there really hasn't been that much
increase in speed and core speed of
processors
those clock speeds have stayed pretty
much the same
maybe they've climbed from 2 gigahertz
to 2.5 gigahertz to
you know maybe you see some things at 3
gigahertz those kinds of things
but it hasn't climbed that much now that
that's sort of the bad news the good
news is
that a lot of actual applications that
people run
have gotten somewhat faster and the main
reason is
that they're not just running on a
single cpu at a time it's not like
you have a a program that's just
sequentially doing this this this this
this
instead you might have a thousand
parallel threads that are running
where different pieces of the program
are all running in parallel so for
example
let's say you are putting an image on
the screen and you've got to decode some
pieces of the image
that are coming in from some from some
stream of data
you might be able to do that by in
parallel
uh dealing with one part of the image at
the same time that you're dealing with
other parts of the image so as far as
you the user are concerned you've got a
a a
a computer that's a thousand times
faster because you've got a thousand
parallel threads operating
now in typical computers the typical uh
like a laptop you might have uh four
core cpus so
your cpu might be able to do four uh
parallel
threads of computation at the same time
of ordinary kinds of computation
but there also are gpus graphics
processing units
that are able to do often thousand or
more parallel computations but they're
not general computations
they're specifically computations where
you have arrays of numbers
and you're able to do the same thing to
every element of that array of numbers
originally gpus were developed for as
their name suggests
rendering graphics and things then they
were really driven a lot by computer
gaming
and uh wanting to have as as as high
quality and as fast as possible
uh graphics for computer games but in
more recent times gpus have been used
for all kinds of purposes
your average just typical program that's
written
in a general purpose way won't run on a
gpu it has to be specially coded
to be able to run on gpu but that's the
main thing that's achieved an increase
in speed as a practical matter
for people running programs now in terms
of the the speed of
of um of actual cpu chips uh it was very
mysterious that um
that there was this sort of inexorable
exponential law that
um that operated because really what was
happening sort of on the ground was
lots and lots of engineering details so
so what limits
the speed of a cpu chip roughly so cpu
chip
has on it these tiny little features
etched into silicon
that represent little tiny wires and
places where the wires cross
to make transistors and switches and so
on and there might be a billion of those
on a modern cpu chip
and they're made by taking essentially
this giant sort of photographic
image of this giant street map that is
the
the network of wires and crossings
between wires
and then essentially just almost
optically
compressing it down actually done with
ultraviolet light because you need to do
that by now
um and sort of uh projecting it down
onto this
this tiny little chip and then what
happens is
where that where the light falls you can
etch away a level
layer of the chip with acid and then
what you what you get left over
is this um is this whole region of of um
of your sort of your your pattern of
wires so to speak
um so that's uh uh but but now
one of the things that limits the speed
so a few things limit the speed of the
chip one is
um there's uh a certain rate at which
you can kind of fill up with electrons
and get rid of electrons
when you go through all of these wires
and switches and so on
uh capacitance of um of the system
and and these days i think it's probably
about 10 000 electrons per bit at least
in memory
in cpus it's probably a little bit more
than that of how many electrons
represent every
bit of information that's going through
the system and the other issue
is that there are many other issues but
another issue is that
um it's the the you can reduce this
capacitance you can release the sort of
uh the the you know how much stuff you
have to schlep around
by reducing the sizes of the features by
getting down to i don't know a few
nanometers few
few billionths of a meter of um of
of size of these individual wires and
individuals
switching areas and so on so one issue
is is can you make that smaller smaller
smaller
and um then there are issues like well
if you have two wires that are really
close to each other
maybe the electrical signal from one
wire there'll be crosstalk with a wire
next to it
how do you make rules for designing the
sort of layout of wires and switches
so that you'll minimize the amount of
crosstalk but still achieve the
objective that the circuit has
so those are a few of the kinds of
issues but
but it's a very uh it's sort of the
really pinnacle of precision engineering
to be able to make anything where you
put a billion you know
uh sort of features on this chip with
with a few nanometer
um uh separation between things that's a
huge achievement to be able to do that
and it requires
a lot of pieces of precision and avoid
you know any little piece of dust that
gets in there that's a big disaster you
have to
have to avoid all those kinds of things
it's just a progressive thing and as
as one tries to build up a sort of
production line for making things
there's always oh well there was this
little thing that goes wrong ten percent
of the time
oh let's fix that oh now there's another
thing that goes wrong three percent of
the time let's fix that
oh now that we've managed to get things
to go to work better
now there's another issue that comes up
and you're progressively improving these
things
and that's why you get this sort of
progressive reduction feature size and
and so on and often when you get to a
different level of feature size
you might have to change the overall
technology you use for so for example
with visible light if you're doing this
etching process and you're using visible
light
there's a minimum scale that you can
deal with because which is determined by
the wavelength of light
um and as you if you want to go below
that scale you have to deal with
ultraviolet light or x-rays
as a way to to basically do that etching
on a smaller scale
and and what tends to happen is that as
you bring up
kind of a new technology a new process
for producing
let's say microprocessors um they'll be
one of one
of the issues is the yield will go down
so typically the way microprocessors are
made there'll be a big wafer
a very pure silicon and then you'll be
etching
all of these different little sort of
circuit patterns onto maybe a thousand
different uh different little regions
on the on top of this wafer and then
what happened each one of those
could turn into a cpu chip let's say but
but the question is which of them
actually work and at what speed and so
what tends to happen in the manufacture
of these things
is you'll produce this whole sort of uh
collection of of
candidate microprocessors and then you
have a testing device
that tests all of them and then some
fraction of them will work and some
fractions something went wrong
maybe it was a little defect in the in
the perfect arrangement of atoms
in the sultan crystal maybe shocker
piece of dust i think that's probably a
rare case now
um maybe it's some other kind of thing
that went wrong and so
some one of these candidate
microprocessors won't work
but the issue is uh if the yield is
sufficiently low if only one percent of
the microprocessors you think you're
building actually work
um it's it's that's bad it's very
expensive to operate
everything just to get one percent yield
um in um
uh the um and then what can also happen
a pretty common thing to be done
is that you'll test these
microprocessors at different speeds and
some of them will be like
that's good that's that works at three
gigahertz so that one
it doesn't work above two gigahertz so
we'll sell that as a as a lower speed
cpu
this this whole problem of yields is a
problem that
affects a lot of kinds of precision uh
manufacturing this type i mean i
remember back um oh probably when was it
probably um when when uh large
displays large flat screen displays
started getting made
there was a a strange thing which
happened for probably a decade
where people did have very large flat
screen displays
but the yields were really low so they
were very very expensive
and the problem with the display is if
something goes wrong with one pixel on
the display and it's dead
you get to see that you're looking at
your display it's like oh my gosh
there's this
dot somewhere on the display it's just
sitting there so
you really can't use that as a
meaningful display if it's something
like a memory chip
you might have ways to just say well
let's just not write data
into that spot where things don't work
properly
but um let's see the the question is um
uh what uh you know so what's what's
kind of happened in the last probably 10
years
is that um uh the sort of the the mua's
law
of exponential increase of speed for
computers has
has flattened off as far as the actual
raw hardware of the computers is
concerned i know
you know we have a lot of servers that
we use for from alpha for example
and uh we you know it's every so often
it's like do we need to buy new servers
not really they'd only be 10 20 percent
faster it doesn't really make much
difference
not worth the money um and back in in
you know in in earlier decades it's like
yeah they just got
twice as fast they just got five times
as fast
um it's kind of a shame if you're
developing software because some
assumptions that i've made for example
about um the complexity of software
systems uh
it's kind of like i'd always assumed
computers will always get faster
so it's okay so long as the complexity
of the software system doesn't increase
things will get faster as far as users
are concerned
by the way another thing that tends to
happen is as time goes
on software gets more and more complex
and there are more layers
that get used and so that can make
things appear to go slower
um even when the computer is running at
the same speed
but um the uh you know today i don't
know how many cpus there are in the
world today i'm i'm guessing on the
order of 100 billion
it depends exactly what you count
whether you count uh only general
purpose
computers that are running sort of
general operating systems or whether you
count
microcontrollers that um are just
because you know a typical car
might have a few hundred
microcontrollers in it
um and uh those are just sort of simple
cpus
that do really just one thing and don't
run a full operating system and so on
um but you know there are probably 100
billion maybe a trillion
uh cpus of of some kind in the world
today
it's a it's a large amount of sort of
organized computation
now what will happen in the future um
you know one of the questions is
uh is one going to be able to make
existing computers much faster
does one have to use completely
different technology i mean the whole
sort of effort of making quantum
computers
i'm not sure that the the official use
of quantum mechanics
to make a magically faster computer i
don't think that's going to pan out
but the idea that there are different
technologies for making computers
um that's a a good potential idea
my own belief based on science is that
to get computation to happen is not
difficult
what's difficult is to get the
computation you want to have happen
i mean let's say you've got a bunch of
molecules in the you know gas in this
room they're swirling around all kinds
of patterns
that's effectively doing a lot of
sophisticated computation the question
is can i feed in
the input can i feed in the program i
want and have that executed
by molecules so to speak or not and
that's one of the interesting challenges
is can one make a for example molecular
scale computer
as i mentioned the you know the
computers we have today maybe it's 10
000 electrons per bit 100 000 electrons
per bit these kinds of things could we
get it down to the point where it's
one electron per bit where it's or where
it's
um where things are operating at the
scale of individual atoms
individual molecules and so on the one
example that we have of that
is in biology in our sort of biological
uh processes are operating at the level
of individual molecules
are doing things in our bodies and are
interacting with each other
and that's an example of sort of
molecular scale computation but we
haven't yet managed to build
sort of computer-like technology that
operates in that kind of way although
i'm quite certain it's possible
it's something i've long been interested
in but i don't think we're quite
there yet in terms of the sort of
ambient technology to understand how to
do it
okay let's see tons more questions here
ah let's see it's a question from joshua
uh if f equals m a and photons have a
mass of zero
how can light sales work okay
interesting question
all right so let's let's unpack that
question a little bit so first of all
what is a light sail
so been a few experiments actually done
on these you get
uh the the the point is that when when
you have light coming
from something whether it's a flashlight
or whether it's the sun
there is a small force that is exerted
by that light
when it bounces off essentially a mirror
now in practice you get this big thing
in space we have a giant
piece of uh reflective mylar or
something that's uh i don't know maybe a
kilometer across if you
and um and potentially you just you have
that so that you're using it
as a as a solar sail for example where
the light from the sun is hitting this
giant
uh sheet of milo has to be very thin and
light otherwise it doesn't
uh that otherwise you're you're wasting
all your effort on moving your sail
which is probably not what the the
you want to actually move a spacecraft
or something so the what's happening is
light
from the sun for example is hitting this
this essentially reflective thing
and it's bouncing back okay so the
question is how does that work
well the answer is that it what's
happening when you have a mirror
a photon is going in one direction and a
photon has momentum
and when when and then when it bounces
just like if it was a billiard ball
when it bounces it's transferring the
momentum is reversed
if it bounces if it hits straight on it
bounces straight back
the momentum is reversed but just like
if you were to hit something with a
billable or just
hit something at all the the the
momentum the changing
changing that momentum and having it
bounce exerts a force on the thing
that's doing the changing of momentum in
that case the
the mirror or the solar cell in this
case so question is
why do photons have momentum and um
there's a in in ordinary kind of
everyday
classical physics there's a a formula
that uh isaac newton originally talked
about back in the 1680s
uh force equals mass times acceleration
so it says uh the amount of so you can
you can turn that equation around and
say acceleration
equals force divided by mass so you want
to make something go faster
you exert a force uh the amount of the
amount that it will go faster
depends on how much force you exert
relative to the mass of the object so if
you have a very massive object
you have to exert more of a force to get
the thing to accelerate more
if you have a very light object you
don't have to
exert very much force to get it to
accelerate okay
so the the question is in that formula
if f equals m a for example how come
if photons have a mass of zero that's m
equals zero
how come that all works well the reason
it works is because that formula doesn't
apply to photons
that formula applies only to objects
that are moving at speeds slow compared
to the speed of light
the the full formula uh has a it's
uh it's it's a has a uh m divided by
square root of 1 minus v squared over c
squared
it has an extra piece and that extra
piece
is a consequence of relativity special
relativity
and that extra piece kind of tells you
that actually that formula doesn't
really apply at all to photons
and instead you pretty much
independently you have to separately say
um a photon has um uh
has an energy and has a momentum and
photons have momentum even though they
have zero mass
and obviously that's a an interesting
fact about the world and as we make our
fundamental theory of physics
uh we have some understanding perhaps of
how how that really works how you get
momentum
even when you don't have mass actually
it's not too hard to see how that works
it's a little bit a little bit elaborate
to explain here but
um uh there's it's it's it's not as
difficult as one might think to have
momentum without mass
in effect so so the full formula people
know you know the famous formula
e equals m c squared so that's a formula
that says
uh that the the mass of an object um if
you were to convert it all to energy
you know annihilate a particle and a
particle something like that convert
everything to energy it's
the mass of the particle times the speed
of light squared is equal to the energy
released
the full formula is e squared equals
um uh
uh yeah e squared equals uh
p squared c squared plus m squared c to
the fourth
so the energy squared is equal to
momentum squared
times um c squared plus
um m squared times c to the fourth
that's the full formula that includes
momentum
and that formula is is much easier to
sort of untangle in terms of of how it
works with photons and
zero mass objects and so on um
let's see
okay it's a question from ringmaster
here as of right now what
do i anticipate the outcome of the
wolfram physics project will be
what practical applications will it have
so
our project is is an attempt to sort of
understand
the lowest level machine code for the
operation of the universe
and what's amazing is that it's going
incredibly well
and i think we really are pretty certain
that we know correctly what the overall
framework for understanding what happens
at sort of the lowest level in our
universe is
and how space is made from discrete
collection of points
where we just know the sort of the way
that they're connected to each other in
a giant hypograph and how time works
by sort of computational processes going
on and how quantum mechanics works by
this sort of
whole network of different possible
histories and so on
all of this stuff seems to be coming
together and all of the stuff we seem to
be able to understand
the things that were discovered in 20th
century physics particularly relativity
and quantum mechanics
we now you know what in the past people
just said
these are facts that are true about the
world we can now say this is why they're
true this is how we build up
to understand why relativity works the
way it does why quantum mechanics works
the way it does and that's very exciting
and uh you know to this point we are
primarily making sort of theoretical
predictions where we say
according to our very low level model
this is how things should work and
that's sort of fitting together and
we're seeing
how it fits together with other kind of
mathematical physics theories people
have had
and a lot of times the sort of
mathematical formalism
can be applied all those kinds of good
things okay so what
well according to our theory space is
not something continuous it's actually
discrete
but it's discrete on extremely small
scale maybe 10 to the minus 100 meters
type scale
that's uh let's see that's a trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion
how many trillions about that many
trillions of the size of a proton
which itself is a
thousand trillionth of a meter across so
we're talking
very very very small distances space is
discrete
uh why is that important well you know
if you had a black hole in your backyard
there are some effects
that would take place around the black
hole where that can matter
somewhat if they're mergers of giant
black holes and things about that can
matter
but most of the time it doesn't really
have much significance at all it's like
saying
it's like does it really matter that
water is made of discrete molecules
most of the time when we drink water
when we slush things around when we have
boats and so on
doesn't make much difference to a boat
that water is made of discrete molecules
rather than being continuous fluid
and it's the same thing with the
structure of space and so on for us
now uh the i think that there are
questions about
does the theory have implications that
one can observe with telescopes looking
at the
large scale structure of the universe
with particle accelerators looking at
the small scale structure
the expectation is that yes there will
be a bunch of those things and they'll
be pretty interesting
and pretty funky effects and surprising
things about you know fluctuations and
dimension of the universe
away from exactly three and all kinds of
things like this
but they're not things that are likely
to have kind of an everyday
oh yes i see that every day type type
consequence
with a few exceptions so i i think
the likelihood of getting to a sort of
invention
that one can actually use uh as a
practical matter
is that is a long-term story i mean i
think
it's like when when newton was inventing
things like we talked about f equals m a
when he was inventing
those kinds of things on his law of
gravity and so on at that time
uh he will have already known that it's
possible to have
satellites orbiting the earth artificial
satellites but you know
1687 you know newton publishes his big
book about
about um applying mathematics to physics
he could have started a satellite launch
company
but it would have been very very very
much too early
because the ambient technology wasn't
there and i kind of feel the same way
about a lot of the things with our
physics project there are things where
we can sort of imagine
that it might be possible eventually but
there's a long chain of engineering to
get there
so one of those i wrote about recently
is can you go faster than speed of light
you know we've been sort of trained by
by discoveries and relativity from 100
years ago
that no nothing can go faster than light
well it turns out that going faster than
light is a bit of a more complicated
story because it depends uh when you say
i'm going to go faster than light
the question is what is space like is
space very much
uniform thing where you're just i'm
going faster than light or is space kind
of a complicated thing itself
where the question of of whether you go
fast and light depends on whether you
can sort of navigate through
all of these complexities of space and
it turns out
it's i'm pretty sure that uh in our
models
that in principle it's possible go
faster than light
but to do that you have to kind of solve
a very very difficult engineering
problem you have to be able to
essentially hack space you have to be
able to decide it's like
if you're in you know gas molecules in a
room
and you ask how long it's going to take
for a gas molecule to go from here to
the other side of the room
well most of the time it takes a really
long time because these gas molecules
they hit another gas molecule it hits
another gas molecule they're kind of
randomly walking
based on hitting one gas molecule and
then another but occasionally there'll
be a gas molecule that
has it exactly right where it exactly
knows you know
this is going to hit this one then this
one then this one and it's going to be
able to go straight across the room
so it's the same kind of thing if we can
sort of hack space to the point where we
can
kind of predict all of the details of
all the sort of microscopic randomness
that happens down at this
10 to the minus 100 meter scale if we
could really hack that and navigate our
way through it
then we could go faster than light or at
least we could send a signal faster than
light
by the way in the history of
telecommunications
people have often had this issue of you
know how fast can you really send a
signal
on a copper wire how fast can you really
send a signal by radio
and a lot of times people said oh
there's a limit because of this because
of that
and then people realize oh well if you
kind of hack
the the substrate if you just figure out
exactly when you send it
how do you correct for this piece of
noise that happens etc etc etc
you can go faster but we're not even
close
to you know use this model to understand
how to go faster than light we can't
even manipulate
things at the level of individual atoms
molecules
let alone something that's trillions and
trillions and trillions of times smaller
than an atom or molecule but i think
you know from the point of view of of um
uh
the significance of our project for the
world at large
i kind of think a lot of the
significance is is more philosophical
and practical
at this point and it's kind of
reminiscent of what happened in the
history of science
long time ago like 500 years ago if you
asked a typical person
you know uh does you know how does the
how does the earth move they would say
the earth is staying still the earth
doesn't move at all
the sun moves around the earth we can
see it every day the sun moves around
the earth
and um the uh we can see it every year
the
the the sun is moving so so
sort of the general belief was well we
can tell we're just standing right here
the earth doesn't move we can tell that
and then copernicus came along and um
and said well actually the mathematics
works out a lot better
we have a much better theory if the
earth goes around the sun
now in in his particular theory the
mathematical thing he was trying to work
out
didn't make much of a difference because
of the way sort of relative motion works
earth goes around the sun sun goes
around the earth kind of same difference
and but there were details of the
mathematics of how that worked with
respect to other planets
that worked a little bit more elegantly
in the way that capernaus did it the the
the previous way of doing it using
ptolemaic epicycles
had been really quite successful and
when it came to just calculating
where's the mars going to be where's
jupiter going to be whatever
that method of calculating worked just
fine it was a little bit bizarre and
ornate and
people couldn't understand why these
weird crystal spheres would move in the
way that they move but you could
calculate what would happen
you get the right answer in fact even
today when we do calculations
we are using mathematics that is
essentially those epicycles again
same calculational method but the
interpretation is
is different well so copernicus came
along and said well actually no
you know it works better and really it
seems like
we should you know in fact the earth
goes around the sun
a revolution so to speak in the um
it's the origin of that word um the
uh the thing that um uh
copernicus i think in it's kind of a
comment on the on the history of science
i mean he waited to publish those ideas
until he was uh until he was dying
basically
um because he was kind of like i don't
want all the blowback from people
saying oh no that can't be true etc et
cetera
instead um people like galileo who is
much more of a kind of activist of his
time
were the ones who kind of uh you know
carried that forward
and pushed it hard but any case the you
know what was the main consequence of
the copernicus
moment the main consequence i think was
that people
got the idea that science can tell you
things that aren't obvious to you
like i think i'm just standing still on
the earth the earth is standing still
how can you be telling me from science
that's not true
the earth is actually moving but it's so
so it's kind of a moment when sort of
people got the idea that science can
tell you things that are not obvious
and you can end up concluding things
from science even though they weren't
obvious to you and
and arguably that whole process over the
course of 500 years might have been
taken a little bit further than it
should have been
and people are now like science is going
to answer everything
you know we can answer everything with
science actually one of the things that
has become clear from from scientific
work that i've done
is that there are limitations if you if
you want to say to science
uh you know you have some system and it
has some rules by which it operates and
you say
what's going to happen according to
those rules in the system well it turns
out
there's a phenomenon i call
computational irreducibility
that basically says you can't know
what's going to happen
except by just running the rule and
seeing what happens so that's kind of a
limitation
to what you might have thought of okay
okay science just tell me what's going
to happen
that can't work there's this
computational irreducibility
that says you have to kind of follow
through the steps and it takes a lot of
effort to find out what happens
in a sense that's not a terrible thing
for us to find out because
it's kind of like the uh if if you could
always take any system in the world
and say what's going to happen in the
end then
it's kind of like a bit of a downer in
terms of leading one's life because it's
like well what's going to happen in the
end
you know the answer is going to be 42
that's the end we can immediately know
that
well no we can't because of
computational irreducibility
the actual process of kind of the the
the emotion you know the
progression through time and and so on
it actually
something real is happening some
computation that isn't reducible is
happening
okay so so in any case but sort of the
copernicus
moment was this kind of trust science
more than you trust your senses
for some purposes i think one of the
things that happens by understanding
sort of what is the universe really made
of how does it really work
what we're discovering is it's
computation all the way down
there's really this idea of computation
these ideas that come out of
sort of the computational paradigm for
thinking about things they really apply
to our universe our universe really
works that way
and it's not like well this computation
is interesting for making computers
but it's not really relevant elsewhere
because really the world you know the
mind works differently this works
differently
that works differently no it's really
computational all the way down
and that means that these ideas like
computational irreducibility
which are a phenomenon of computation
their ideas that actually matter
everywhere because really our universe
is really computational all the way down
and it's just like back in in the days
of you know copernicus galileo newton
and so on
people got ideas like force and momentum
and so on
they got ideas about about how the world
works and these sort of paradigms of
thinking about things
acceleration etc etc etc these were
things that
came out of that thinking about
mechanics and now we use them as
metaphors to think about a lot of kinds
of things in the world
we talk about you know some some idea
having momentum or something
actually in that case it's just a
metaphor it's not like we think it
actually is moving with a mass and
velocity and so on
it's just a metaphor that we understand
because we understand kind of the
logical structure of the way that
mechanics works
well i think what we're seeing now is
that
we need to understand ideas like
computational irreducibility
and we need the reason that if nothing
else told us we need to understand them
is
because that's fundamentally how our
universe works it's really computational
all the way down
and that means that one of the things
that we have to think about
is in that but well in this case
rather than the mechanics case where
it's just a metaphor we don't actually
think an idea has momentum
we really do think that computational
irreducibility
applies to lots of kinds of things in
the world not
just for example physics so that's
that's a little bit of a
um of a comment there
oh my there's so many things here all
right um
okay from mikhail
what is more difficult for you to create
things or to explain how they work to
others
you know for me those two things
have increasingly merged in my life
so you know i
sometimes when you do research it's like
okay
figure out what's true and then after
you've finished
go explain it to people and so a very
typical thing is
uh a lot of what i do is is based on
computer experiments
and a lot of what one does in computer
experiments is making pictures
making uh of of things
and sometimes back a long time ago i
used to make the following mistake i
used to say
okay i'll figure out things at research
level i'll have it kind of hacky nasty
pictures
and then when i finished i'll go and
i'll make really nice pictures so that i
can explain
things to people okay so i do that
and then you know i do all the things i
come to various conclusions then i make
the nice pictures then look at the nice
pictures and i'd say
oh my gosh now that i have these nice
pictures i can see all this other stuff
that i didn't notice before so i
realized that was a bad approach
and that instead the making the nice
pictures that would be suitable to show
to other people
is something that's worth doing early in
the process of doing the research
not as an afterthought because honestly
showing it being able to show it to
other people is as much
being able for me to understand it
myself so i think it's been um
uh for me it's it's um
you know i you know things like
uh these um uh um these
these um events that i've been doing um
uh trying to answer questions here this
is very educational for me
whatever whatever educational value it
may have for other people it's certainly
educational for me
trying to actually uh uh in real time
answer a range of questions and
understand how to um
uh how to explain things um but but
increasingly for me i
you know i never really believe anything
that i figured out
until i can get it to the point where
i've ground it down to something that's
simple enough
that i can explain it to other people or
explain to myself
or sometimes that i can write it down as
a way
in a way that i would imagine i could
explain to somebody else
and increasingly the things that i write
i i'm a fast enough and
a fluent enough writer that increasingly
the things i write i'll just write them
once and then i'll show them to other
people as well
back when i was younger i would write
them and i'd never show them to anybody
else
i would use them only for myself but but
um but
that sort of changed over time
um
okay question from george here has the
physics project shed any light on
protein
folding um not really yet i mean let me
explain that problem
so uh
we are made of proteins those are the
that's the most common kind of molecule
um in our cell and things like water and
so on proteins
are these collections of blocks of atoms
that form amino acids
and our proteins might have anything
from a few amino acids
to millions of amino acids all in a
chain
and the question is you've got all this
chain of amino acids and
the question is and that about 20 kinds
of amino acids that exist in us
and the question is when you have this
big long molecule that's in this long
chain
what does it actually do does it does it
stain a long chain does it
fold itself up into a little globule
what does it do
and different molecules for different
purposes do different things like actin
filament actin is the molecule in our
muscles that's a protein
and it's got this triple helix thing and
it's a long
thin thing that just kind of stretches
out just like you kind of expect in a
muscle
whereas other molecules like hemoglobin
for example is another protein
hemoglobin globules itself up into a
little glob
and has a little pocket inside it and
that pocket is where the iron atom goes
in
that is the thing that gets used to
transport oxygen in our blood
um and so that's a a different shape of
molecule and so the protein folding
problem is the question
given if i tell you the sequence or
amino acids
that are in a protein can you work out
what shape the protein
will be and it's been a difficult
problem because roughly what happens is
some amino acids are typically amino
acids that
are sitting in water for example some
proteins are sitting in water
some amino acids are hydrophobic in the
sense that they like to
they're afraid of water they like to
sort of withdraw from the water that's
around the molecule
some are hydrophilic they like to expose
themselves to the water
and uh there are different forces of
attraction between different amino acids
and so on
and so you put all those things together
and then the question is well what shape
will the protein be
and in a first approximation you can say
well there's a the lowest energy the
thing that is the thing it most wants to
be that shape
you can sort of compute with a computer
what that will be but it's very hard
computation
and because there are many many many
possibilities and there's not an easy
way to say oh it's going to be this way
versus that way
and and they've been basically two
approaches to doing this one is
just from scratch say i know the force
laws between all these different pieces
of the protein
now what will be the minimum energy
configuration how it fold up that's sort
of
way number one that's the first
principles way the other way is
let's just look at the 30 000 proteins
or whatever it is now
that exists in that we know in humans or
a hundred thousand but
maybe hundreds several hundred thousand
that um whose structure is known
and let's just compare those with
whatever protein we're being told so
you know i give you a new protein it's
like well that's kind of like
hemoglobin for a chicken or something so
it's you know so therefore it will be
this shape so those have been two
approaches
uh with modern machine learning it does
seem that the that
it goes you know one of these approaches
wins then the other one wins i think
these
days it looks like with sort of modern
machine learning that the approach of
let's look at what's happened before and
extrapolate from that
seems to be probably the winning
approach these days but the question is
uh but it's also a very complicated
thing because it's not really right
to say just in the abstract how will the
protein fold up
because the protein gets produced
somehow when a protein is made it's
coming off a ribosome it's being
it's being it's being written sort of
one amino acid at a time and
that process if there are other
molecules hanging around that are kind
of chaperoning this process
they can affect what what shape the
protein will form into
when it's originally created and there
are other things that can happen to the
protein
that will cause it to form into a
different shape than not just oh what's
the mineral energy
configuration so it's a kind of
complicated thing and sometimes
misfolding of proteins may possibly have
important medical consequences in
different cases i mean people their
theories about alzheimer's disease and
so on
that have to do with that and there are
uh prions and things which which
affect uh protein folding and and all
kinds of all kinds of things like that
but um so so the question is
you know how can we make progress with
this and does our physics project
contribute
i don't really see a connection uh right
now between sort of what we're thinking
about in our physics project and this
problem of protein folding
um it's it's my impression though
you know the real challenge is if i give
you a random sequence of amino acids
what shape will it fold up into can you
figure that out
um then then you know you might say well
okay let's try it let's test it
the problem is actually knowing what
shape it made is actually pretty hard
because you've got this molecule it's in
some shape how do you know what shape a
molecule is
the a couple of techniques but the the
sort of the sort of the
the best one is probably x-ray
crystallography you have to make a
crystal
based on these molecules and a big
complicated molecule it's hard to make
it turn into a crystal
it's hard to line up all those molecules
to get them to arrange themselves nicely
to make a crystal once you have a
crystal you can use
x-ray diffraction as a way to know what
the
what the shape of the things inside the
crystal is at least up to some ambiguity
um but that's i can talk about people
are interested maybe sometime i can
explain how
x-ray crystallography works but that's
kind of the but you have to
you have to make a crystal of something
which is really quite hard if it's a big
molecule
okay um
ah let's see
um
so many interesting questions here i'm
just um trying to
um
a lot of interesting things here okay
let's try a few
few different things here all right we
have a question from emmett
how does black hole merging work
okay so
first of all uh what is a black hole
a black hole is the black holes that we
mostly know about today
are collapsed stars stars a bit more
massive than the sun
they they uh eventually use up all of
their essentially nuclear fuel
and they enter they then collapse
and what happens is so much mass
exists in the star and collapses that
eventually the escape velocity
becomes larger than the speed of light
for earth our
the escape velocity if you fire rocket
out into space
if it's going more than 25 000 miles an
hour it will escape the earth's gravity
um for the sun for example if it's going
more than a hundred thousand miles an
hour it will escape the gravity of the
sun
when you have a lot of mass in a very
small region the escape velocity goes up
and there comes a point where the escape
velocity is more than the speed of light
and at that point nothing can escape the
object and that's why it's called a
black hole because things
fall into it but are pulled in by
gravity
but nothing escapes at least that's
roughly true
the uh um but but so what happens in
black hole merger
is this so uh okay
so the sun we're kind of a um
uh uh the sun is an individual star with
planets going around it
many stars in our galaxies are binary
stars there are two stars that are
orbiting around each other
and sometimes there may be planets
orbiting around that binary star system
sometimes you can imagine a very exotic
world
where you maybe even have a ternary star
system and where you have planets that
are having figure eight orbits between
you know even with the binary star
system are sort of figure eight orbit
between the two stars
and you can imagine all kinds of weird
things where you have different
configurations of stars in the sky
uh it's a little bit of a downer for
those kinds of things that it's hard to
maintain
a stable orbit for billions of years
that has sort of a figure eight shape
and stone it might be possible
but it's a lot easier to maintain the
kind of circular elliptical orbits that
we have
around a single star or to maintain
orbits outside of you know the binary
stars are orbiting around very close in
and then there are planets much further
away
but any case so a lot of stars in our
galaxy are
are our binary stars um and
um so one thing that can happen is you
can have two binary stars
and they both reach the sort of end of
their life as stars and they both
collapse
at different times probably and turn
into black holes
and so you have these two black holes
orbiting each other a binary black hole
system okay so then what happens well
normally
when um uh if if things are orbiting
each other
you know for example the um um
with um the moon orbiting the earth
the moon slowly moves slightly further
away from the earth
um as as um as a result of uh the moon
is
is um it's just uh gradually gradually
gradually losing angular momentum
and moving slightly further away from
the earth um what can happen
in a um but there are other cases where
things
spiral in and usually you have to lose
angular momentum to spiraling you have
to
you have to be um you have to either be
be
something has to be sort of uh some kind
of frictional force of some kind
has to be making you kind of lose that
kind of momentum so that you're not so
you're no longer just
in in orbit going around it's like when
you twirl something around
if there wasn't any air resistance it
would just keep twirling forever
um and uh but you know the question is
is there resistance
that causes the thing to slow down as it
slows down
if it's it's the it's the sort of
centrifugal force that's holding it out
in the orbit and if it slows down then
it gradually will sort of spiral in
and um and and then and then the things
will crash into each other
so what happens in a binary black hole
system is that
gradually the the black holes lose
lose energy losing momentum they spiral
in to the point where
they crash into each other so why do
they spiral in
the the the variety of different effects
um one some effects have to do with
accretion disks and gas and so on but
other effects have to do with the
emission of gravitational radiation um
and
uh okay let's explain how that works so
so normally if we have uh
an electric charge for example and we
just wiggle the electric charge up and
down
that will make an electromagnetic wave a
radio wave
that's uh it's the it's the way that
works is
is uh just the motion of a charge
produces actually the acceleration of a
charge
produces um an electromagnetic wave it's
an it
has an electrical effect and also a
magnetic effect and it produces this
electromagnetic wave
so a prediction of einstein's general
theory of relativity from 1915
was that there should also be
gravitational waves that it should be
possible
if you have a a massive object that
produces gravity
that it should be possible by kind of
squidging the object around
to have it produce uh gravitational
waves just like
a moving charge produces electromagnetic
waves so in a sense a moving mass
produces gravitational waves it's a
little more tricky if you just move a
mass up down up down up down you won't
get
um gravitational waves you need to
basically have
a mass that kind of uh goes it's a
quadrupole deformation where the mass
kind of squashes down
and and comes out and like that but um
in um when you have one mass an orbit
around another
you do get gravitational radiation um
and uh
that in fact i think einstein even
worked out the formula for that
the rate of energy lost due to
gravitational radiation but in any case
the the what happens is what
gravitational radiation produces this
uh this so gravity is interpreted as
this kind of deformation of space
and gravitational radiation is the sort
of wave-like deformation
of space that moves so far as we can
tell at the speed of light
and one consequence that that wave-like
deformation of space
has is that if you have a the
appropriately arranged collection of
masses
that deformation of space will move
those masses slightly
and um so uh
what um what happens in a black hole
merger is
that these black holes these pair of
black holes this they're
losing energy perhaps through
gravitational radiation they eventually
lose enough energy that
splat they ran into each other and in a
few seconds
the um uh what has to happen is that
these two black holes which were these
nice
basically spherical things or more or
spherical things
they have to they merge with each other
and um
that that process is is a very violent
process
and in fact in that process uh some part
of the
the mass of those black holes is
converted into pure energy
in the form of gravitational waves um
and some part of it
uh ends up being making a bigger black
hole
so in the first black hole merger that
was detected a few years ago
by a gravitational wave detector um that
was
i think it it um it dissipated about one
and a half solar masses
in a matter of a couple of seconds so
that means that
that what was happening as these two
black holes merged to turn into one
black hole
they um uh the um uh
they it was such a violent event that
the equivalent of one and a half times
the mass of our sun
was converted into pure energy in
gravitational waves
and that meant that even though that
event was happening a third of the way
across the universe
we could still detect it with a
gravitational wave detector here on
earth
that was measuring deformations and
distance moving
masses by amounts that are a small
fraction of the size of an atom so it's
a
it's a subtle effect but still that
merger of black hole
uh you know a third of the way across
the universe still had a measurable
effect here on earth
so one question is well you know these
two things run into each other
and they make another black hole what
are they really making how does that
really work
well one feature of black holes
it's called the no hair theorem for
black holes it basically says
any black hole is like any other black
hole all you need to know about it is
its mass and how fast it's spinning
around
and that uh if you have a black hole
that isn't spinning around at all
it will always be a perfect sphere it's
it's boundary it's event horizon will
always be a perfect sphere
and there's nothing when you look at it
from the outside
there's nothing it it just looks like a
perfect sphere and that's a that's a
a prediction of general relativity that
that should be that way that there's no
sort of there no bumps on it it's not
like it's the surface of the sun where
there are all kinds of
you know solar prominences that are
coming out and all kinds of things like
that no
it's just as far as the gravitational
part of the black hole is concerned
it's just a perfect spherical thing
now what happens inside the black hole
well
we won't get to know that because at
least
for the most part because anything that
falls into a black hole doesn't get out
again
and so it's like something could be
going on there could be this whole
elaborate thing happening inside the
black hole
but it can't signal to us outside so
it's as if we don't you know
if we doesn't matter what's going on
it's actually a very subtle thing what
happens inside a black hole
is not really that well understood it's
known that outside
it will so it can look like this perfect
sphere of um
of event horizon but inside oh who knows
what's happening
and maybe there's even a place where
where the usual structure of space-time
breaks down that's both what general
relativity says and it's what our models
say actually more to the point in a
non-rotating black hole
there's a very bizarre thing at the
center of the black hole there's this
place where
time simply stops where time
where the progression of time just comes
to an end well it's stopped right there
so all kinds of weird things happen but
from outside the back hole all you know
is this perfect sphere well if you have
two of these perfect sphere black holes
and they merge with each other somehow
the end result has to be a perfect
sphere
and in the process of it turning into
that it kind of blobs around it's kind
of like a bell
where you ring the bell by you know it's
a big sort of thing and it
it gradually kind of what will happen is
it sort of
has it gradually deforms and eventually
after a sufficiently long time it's kind
of lost enough energy through
gravitational radiation it ends up in
this perfect sphere form
and we get to see the little wiggles as
um uh as um as that ring down process
happens
and and for the case of the first black
hole merger i think it was about five
seconds
of you know
[Music]
and after five seconds it's all over all
of those fluctuations from the very
violent event
of uh the formation of that merged black
hole have gone away
now today i think i think the
gravitational wave detectors
are seeing maybe an event every day or
so so it's
somewhere in the universe there's a
black hole merger every day or so
um and that's you know we can kind of
work out how that works there are about
10 to 11 stars in our galaxy
100 billion stars in our galaxy there
are about 100 billion galaxies
that tells us how many stars there are
in the universe we know how many binary
stars there are we know et cetera et
cetera et cetera
we can work out and i think probably
we're at the point where we can see most
black hole mergers that happen anywhere
in the universe
um and that's uh it's kind of a
remarkable thing that one can kind of
kind of tell that it's a little bit like
you know if there's an earthquake that
happens anywhere on the earth
seismometers can detect it it's sort of
the same kind of thing but for the
structure of space
observing black hole mergers anywhere in
the universe
okay um
question here from jonas about is there
a theory about what type of particles a
black hole will be made of
yeah well that's a subtle thing because
the very idea of a particle we've got
all these particles electrons protons
whatever
when a black hole is formed all of those
things collapse
and they're all being pulled by gravity
and the effect of a black hole is this
deformation of space
that that results in this this event
horizon
where things can go in but can't come
out and so
all of the things that were all the
features of particles they're all
irrelevant
because all we see in a black hole is
something to do with the structure of
space
and at that in that sense a black hole
is not made of particles
a black hole inside the event horizon
all bets are off about what's going on
so it's a more complicated story
but as far as the structure of the
cement horizon it's a structure
it's a feature of space it's a feature
of the structure of space
it's not something that is made of
material particles
now if we really want to get funky
there's the following question
uh we talk about big black holes made
from collapsed stars and things like
that but what about really really tiny
black holes
one thing that i've thought was a
possibility actually since i was a kid
and i
didn't really the ways in which it might
be a possibility have changed a bit
but one of the really bizarre
possibilities is maybe all the particles
we know and love like electrons
and quarks and so on maybe they are in
fact really tiny black holes in some
sense
and i think there's a there's a pretty
good chance that that's true
um and that in fact in some sense and
it's a little bit of a
subtle sense all those things are like
absolutely tiny versions of black holes
that are like little regions of the
universe that work in a different way
than other regions of the universe
but in in an ordinary black hole
situation what you're seeing that
counts as the black hole is a feature of
the structure of gravity and the
structure of space-time
not something directly made from
material particles
um
let's see
um
okay
gosh there's a question from yourself
this is one i'm not an
unexpected question from what's my
experience and opinion about alchemy
and is it possible to incorporate a
modernized version of it into
mathematica that is a
that's a weird and funky question thank
you
okay well first of all let's talk about
what alchemy is or was
so back in
um particularly in the middle ages
people
were uh trying to understand
what these days we would talk over think
of as chemistry
how different materials can have
chemical reactions produce other
materials and so on
at the time there was a lot done on
metallurgy on how you can go from the
ore of a metal
uh like uh you know iron ore which is
just kind of a rock
and how you can get out of it something
which is just metallic iron or how you
can do that for aluminum which is more
difficult
or maybe my favorite element tungsten
whose ore is whose
principle or is wolframite w04
um i actually don't know as much as i
should about how you get
tungsten out of wolframite that's kind
of embarrassing um
you know you you heat it up you combine
it with some other chemical and you get
tungsten now but i'm not exactly sure
how it works but anyway so there was a
lot done
of trying to figure out how you could go
from like a rock
to metal um how you could you know heat
it up have it react with other things
and what's happening in those chemical
reactions as we now know today
is that individual molecules uh
associated with the rock are being
broken down and the atoms that are in
them
that are these atoms of the metal are
coming out and
and you're then they're forming into
this this whole substance which is the
metal and so on
okay so so a lot of the sort of question
of alchemy was
was there some some way uh the
particular one that people were most
interested in was the
transmutation of lead into gold you know
lead is a pretty cheap material that's
pretty common
gold is pretty rare and uh uh
and has been considered pretty valuable
and the question is could you somehow in
your lab
just go and take a big lump of lead and
turn it into gold
and if you could do that then it's kind
of like uh
people often claim for for you know
people who do
in the uh um in in financial markets and
things you kind of
you make money out of nothing so to
speak um
the uh actually it's usually lots of
hard work to do it but
different quite different topic but any
case the the um
uh so the question was could you do
things like transmute lead into gold
um and so people had a whole elaborate
uh ways of trying to do that
and and all sorts of skullduggery of
figuring out you know magical ideas for
how that might work uh in the end it
didn't work
finally it was understood that lead and
gold are really different kinds of atoms
that the nucleus of the
of the lead atom is different has a
different number of protons in it than
the nucleus of the gold atom
and by purely chemical processes by
purely sort of heating things up and
you know to ordinary temperatures of a
few thousand degrees maybe in a flame
you can't make lead and gold transmute
into each other
now what was discovered once nuclear
physics was understood in the 1940s
and 1950s is well yes if you have high
enough energy particles and you can
really monkey around with the nuclei
of these of these some elements yes you
can do things like you can make it take
a lead nucleus
and you can knock out some of its
protons you can knock it down so that
it's a gold nucleus
um but that process is hardly a
cost-effective process
for making uh gold out of lead but so
the the um
the the sort of the idea of alchemy was
this um you know
what were the mechanisms by which you
can transmute one material into another
and that really turned into uh what
became modern chemistry i mean modern
chemistry was really
uh once people started understanding
that there were atoms which was kind of
early to mid 1800s and then by the late
1800s
there was sort of the huge development
of industrial chemistry
and the the concept that you could
really make things and then
then later in my when was it 1910s 1920s
plastics for example
which are long hydrocarbon molecules it
was understood how to
how to create those and those were the
first kind of really successful
synthetic materials
which hadn't existed in nature but which
were created by chemical reactions and
so on
and that was kind of what what the whole
business of alchemy turned into was was
chemistry
um and the chemistry is
is um you know in chemistry what you
expect
is that you're gonna make something in a
chemical reaction and it's like
heat this pour in this you know cool
this do this do that
do the other thing and typically in
industrial processes for making things
the most sophisticated these days will
have maybe 20 maybe 25 steps in them
you know do this do that do the other
thing put it in this machine
use this catalyst do this thing et
cetera et cetera et cetera
sort of an interesting question of could
one extend that
if you said let's make something where
we can have a hundred
steps where we make the material by
using a hundred different steps
then you know what kinds of things could
we do and there's some hope that with uh
with kind of automated labs and uh
more kinds of sophistication in terms of
the way one computationally thinks about
designing chemical synthesis processes
the process of
of going you know if you're trying to
make some chemical what you're ending
having to do
you've got these molecules you're trying
to rearrange the molecules so one little
ring from one molecule turns into
something which attaches to something
else
it's very hard to do that you can't like
say let me just pick up the atoms and do
this to them
what you have to do is do it very
indirectly by knowing oh when this
molecule is in this state it will have
some
uh electric charge that will pull on
this that will align with this molecule
and pull in this way
and do things kind of at the level of
molecules that's a hard thing to figure
out
and um this process actually there's
some ideas recently
that we've had on sort of uh how to
automate the process of doing chemical
synthesis
i've tried to figure out just what
series of moves do you have to make
to turn a chemical a molecule to go go
from having
you know a trillion trillion molecules
of this type to a trillion trillion
molecules of that type
just what sequence of moves do you have
to go to to get from here to there
and how do you get it to the point where
enough molecules have gone through
whatever process you're defining
that you get a significant amount of the
material you're trying to produce
so those are that's sort of the the
modern version of that
and um the question of of um
uh actually we've done a lot of work in
world language in recent times
to support molecular computation about
molecules
um just as we can compute things about i
don't know
images or graphs or mathematical
formulas
so now we can compute things about
molecules and um
that's sort of a precursor to being able
to do these kinds of things that i'm
talking about
like uh more streamlined automated
chemical synthesis and so on
in a sense doing with what we know about
chemistry
doing in a sense what what the
alchemists wanted to do coming up with a
procedure
for going from here to there for being
able and really the the ultimate goal
is i draw you a picture of a molecule
you make that molecule
that's not something that one can do in
chemistry today
it's a very difficult thing you know
there are particular molecules in
particular
complicated synthesis processes get
invented to do them
i mean back in the day people uh people
would say i draw you a molecule
out of carbon atoms that looks like a
dog can you make
dog a seed you know can you find a
series of chemical reactions that will
make
a molecule that is in that shape well it
would be nice to have a sort of
systematic way to do that
perhaps we don't know for sure um
perhaps
by having appropriate shapes and
molecules we could achieve all kinds of
things one of the things that's
difficult to know
is you know given a particular molecule
particular shape what are its properties
going to be that's
not an easy thing to work out either i
mean one of the things that was a big
surprise
for carbon okay so so carbon exists in
two common forms
it exists as graphite and it exists as
diamond
so in graphite the atoms of carbon in
graphite
it's crystal but the atoms are arranged
in these sheets there's sort of
uh sheets of of carbon atoms that make
up a graphite a piece of graphite and so
it has various properties like it can
slide and
and so on diamond exact same material
just a bunch of carbon atoms but diamond
the the carbon atoms
are arranged but when diamond is
produced for example at high pressure
um the the the carbon atoms kind of move
around so
they're packed in a certain way in a
diamond crystal they're all arranged in
this particular
particular geometrical structure all
infinite it's sort of a
very large thing which is just repeats
the same structure repeats repeats
repeats repeats repeats
so that's some so that's the two forms
of carbon that were known for a long
time were graphite and diamond
but turned out there was actually
another form of carbon that the people
hadn't discovered
um called uh well it's often called
buckminster fullerene after buckminster
fuller
who and what it is is it's carbon atoms
that are arranged not in an infinite
crystal but they're arranged a little
cluster
that um basically is like if you have a
soccer ball
which has pentagons and hexagons you you
don't look at the pentagons and hexagons
you look at the the um the corners
between all of those
and you look at the network of corners
and um you just
then turns out that this version of
carbon
is is made from carbon atoms that are
arranged
at the positions of that network of
corners that you would find on a soccer
ball
and um and so that's a carbon 60 is um
the 60 of those those points and and
that that's the simplest form
um and that's that's a different form of
carbon and there's also a version of it
where you can make it into tubes
so-called graphene
tubes um where uh where you've
essentially got um well it's a slightly
different thing it's kind of like
like miniature version of graphite all
rolled in a tube and and that
probably has some very interesting
properties it's very good electrical
conductor
it has all kinds of other interesting
properties and it may be the future even
of of what
what certain kinds of uh electric
circuits are made out of
in any case that form of carbon the the
buckyball form of carbon wasn't known
until the 1970s even 1980s
and it's actually very common it
actually exists in soot and things
it just there wasn't a good method for
even detecting that was there
and then once you have it it's like
what's it good for you know i think um
uh as such the the buckyballs as such i
don't think have found that many uses i
mean there was a kind of
a whole non-stick frying pan story with
that but i'm not sure if even that
panned out
not to make too much of a pun but um the
uh
in any case the but the basic point is
you know let's say
sort of a holy grail of kind of
metachemistry is just make a molecule in
whatever
shape you want but one of the challenges
is what shape do you want
what shape of molecule will be useful
some molecules for example
might have little pockets in them that
could have i mentioned hemoglobin where
where you know there's a little pocket
that fits a single a single iron atom
into it and that's useful you could
imagine a molecule which had would have
a little space inside it
where for example it would have
something where where
it would have some effect where you know
with with uh
uh electromagnetic radiation for example
you get the molecule do something very
special
with radiation of a certain frequency
because it has a little pocket which has
some particular thing inside it maybe
that will be useful for delivering drugs
internally
for something or something like this
there but you know it's kind of
a what's your imagination about what the
molecule might do
and then how do you actually make it and
is there a systematic way of kind of
doing
of creating the kind of the chemical
doing a series of chemical actions
to to produce a molecule of exactly that
that form
okay i think um we should wrap up real
well fairly soon here um let's try and
do a few more of these
um
okay there's a question it's a question
from ringmaster about the nature of time
travel
um time machines depicted in science
fiction stories and so on
you know time travel is a bit of a
logical mess
uh in our theory of physics time travel
is is simply outright
definitionally impossible okay so
so let's let's talk about time travel
the most interesting time travel
is time travel to the past time travel
to the future
it's a little bit of a weird business
because one way time travel to the
future
is pretty easy you just do nothing you
just sort of hibernate
you say like if you're a computer and if
your brain was sort of uh
computers and you say you want to do
time travel to the future
okay just stop just switch yourself off
for 10 years and then wake up again okay
you've time traveled to the future
that's one version of it what does it
mean to time travel to the past
it means that you're somehow from what
you know now
you're going back to affect something
that happened in the past
how does that work well in in our view
of time
in our model of physics for example time
is the inexorable process
of of the universe computing what it
will do next
and that's not something where you can
say the universe has computed what it
will do next
okay it's going to go back and compute
something it already computed that just
doesn't make any sense
now in the mathematical theory of
general relativity of the theory of
gravity
it is possible to have what are called
closed time-like curves
a closed a time-like curve is a curve
where
what what to some entity that's that's
following this
this sort of path through space time
it's as if time is progressing as you go
down along this curve
and a closed time like curve means it
just seems like time is progressing to
the future
as far as you're concerned time is
progressing to the future but when
people look at you from the outside
it's as if you weren't back in time and
you make a closed cycle
where you're progressing to the future
but actually go back in time
and then progress to the future again
well
the presence of those things even the
mathematical theory of general
relativity
is actually a very strange and
problematic thing
but really what that means is when there
is a closed timeline curve
what it really means is that there has
to be a certain consistency
between the past and the future because
the past and the future are more
connected usually
the future is connected to the past only
by virtue of the fact that the future
emerges
by doing things by computing things from
the past
but when you have a close time-like
curve it is as if the future is
connected to the past
in a more detailed way and so that means
there has to be sort of consistency
between the future and the past and so
in your average piece of science fiction
it's some uh you um
uh it's kind of like you're thinking
what's going on and you're gonna go
and um you know the future for you is
going to the past
and that just doesn't make any sense
because the way that that has to work is
if if your future
becomes past then there has to be
consistency between
what happens from that past and what
happens
in your actual future and so really
these closed time-like curves
just add a certain consistency condition
about how the past and the future
have to be consistent and that doesn't
mean that you get
as a matter of sort of thinking about
what's going on to think oh i could
yeah the real issue is could you choose
to do anything different in the past
the answer is no because really the
existence of this close timelike curve
has already defined a consistency
between the past and the future
so the notion of of of time travel where
you say i'm going to decide
to go to the past and decide what i'm
going to do in the past
it just can't work it's just not a
that's a sort of logically consistent
thing to imagine
so despite the fact there's all kinds of
nice fiction that you can make
um based on it but i don't think it's
something you can really produce in
reality
all right two last questions here and
then i i need to wrap up
um question from jonas here
um about
whether there can be things like
computer architectures
that don't use binary arithmetic
circuits
will they be used in the future so
one feature of computers as they exist
today so
at the lowest level in a computer what
you're dealing with is bits
are there electrons there or are there
not electrons there one or zero
and um the there's a sort of question of
can you make other kinds of systems that
don't just deal with a one or zero one
or zero
whole giant arrays of billions of ones
and zeros are there other things you can
do
so one thing people imagine in the early
days of computers is maybe you
do better if you had zero one and minus
one or zero one and two
like ternary computers where you have um
uh
not just two possible states but three
doesn't really make much
difference because if you can encode
three different states you can always do
that with a pair
of binary bits you just say 0 0
represents 0
1 1 represents 1 and let's say i don't
know 0
1 represents 2 or something like this
however you choose to do it
more consistently you say 0 0 represents
0 0 1 represents 1
1 0 represents 2 1 1 represents three
i mean you're just using pairs of bits
to encode those those different things
but people did in the early days in
1950s actually people built
like ternary computers was a famous
russian computer that was a
base three computer i don't think it had
any particularly notable
features it certainly the way that you
do arithmetic there's
some little elaborate tricks to do with
the way that you deal with negative
numbers and things that that can be done
in in
internal arithmetic but it's not it's
not notably different
the one thing that one could imagine
that would be notably different is to
not use a digital
computer but instead to do use more of
an
analog computer so the reason our
current computers are called digital
it's like you know counting in your
fingers it's like one finger two finger
three fingers four fingers
it's not like we say we have 1.726
fingers it's like it's you know it's
whole numbers of fingers that we're
dealing with
and that's um that's kind of the notion
of digital computers is that everything
is just whole numbers
you know ultimately made from ones and
zeros
but analog computers the idea is that
there is
a a continuous saying of sliding scale
instead of saying there's a one or a
zero
it's like there's any number between
zero and one analog computers were also
popular in 1940s 1950s
they didn't really work out very well um
the
what happened is in an analog computer
it's like a typical electric circuit
where you can say well i've got this
voltage i've got six volts i've got
6.027 volts i've got 6.1 volts there's a
kind of a
arbitrary voltage that you get somewhere
and that's
a and so you can imagine just arranging
the voltage to mean what whatever you
want it to mean
there were a number of reasons why it
didn't work out that well one reason was
it was hard to know exactly what you
were computing if if you're doing that
kind of computation and it's off by a
little bit
well the number's just off by a little
bit but how much of a little bit
is enough that you get nonsense when
you're dealing with digital computation
it's like the bit is either correct it's
a one
or it's incorrect it's a zero let's say
and it's it's easier to correct for
errors in that type of situation you can
do
extra computation you can you know check
consistency
of things you'd say this is right this
is wrong an analog computer was much
harder to do that it was like well it's
a bit wrong
we don't know whether it's so wrong as
to be misleading or not so wrong or
whatever else
also in as as we move towards our
current theory of physics
ultimately analog computation will not
get you anywhere the universe is
ultimately really made of digital things
it's ultimately made of discrete points
and so on so ultimately at a
sufficiently low
small scale although it's a scale
unbelievably much smaller than than
what's relevant for practical technology
today
on a sufficiently small scale analog
can't win
but on the scale of actual existing
computers it might be useful
and it must be said that in a typical
computer there is
analog electric circuitry um for example
uh there's less and less of it actually
but um
sometimes things to do with power
supplies
sometimes things to do with maybe uh um
sound generation sometimes some other
things like that they're dealing with
these sort of continuous scale of
voltages rather than just on or off type
type things um they're also our efforts
in there have been efforts repeated
efforts to do things like image
processing using analog circuits
maybe to do things with neural networks
where you're having artificial neural
nets where instead of just saying
it's on or off you say well it's a
sliding scale maybe that's even more
realistic to how biology does it
although i don't think so i'm in biology
actually strangely enough you might have
thought biology would just be
oh there's a certain concentration or
not but actually there is little
vesicles of
neurotransmitter that seem to exist
where it's like you only get you know
you get
100 vehicles or you get 105 vehicles and
you don't have
a um as kind of a continuous sliding
scale there
but so so it's not looking so promising
that uh there can be something different
from um that i mean there may be some
small
optimizations that can be done but the
whole you know
another issue is the whole apparatus of
kind of inventing software and so on
that's all deeply based on the idea of
digital computers
we know how to program digital computers
we know this idea of universal
computation
that works for digital computers we
don't have any similar idea for analog
computers it's an interesting question
you know in a digital computer you can
have a fixed piece of computer hardware
and by feeding in a different program
you get the computer to do different
things
there's a question if you were doing
that with analog computer
is there a way of making a universal
analog computer
whereby just setting a bunch of switches
and things differently
you get it to do any function any analog
function
nobody knows actually there's some
interesting mathematics around that
question
um but it's a pretty undefined it's it's
not it's not well well understood
and it's something where it's like well
you know
making any function you want you know
you can say a mathematical function you
can plot it it kind of wiggles up and
down or whatever
or it makes some it's it's some smooth
curve you say well i want
any curve however wiggly it is and that
gets to be a very difficult mathematical
question
to define what you mean by that kind of
wiggliness what kind of wiggliness you
can put into the program
that sets up the wiggly out curve that
you're trying to produce and so on
it's all a bit complicated and it's it's
not well well developed and
i my feeling is that probably um
i don't think it's going to be that
fruitful
all right um one last question here
from uh vienna i'm currently in high
school what advice would you give to an
aspiring mathematician
um well so
you know mathematics is uh by aspiring
mathematician
i am assuming that you mean research
mathematics
so discovering new things in mathematics
you know one feature of mathematics is
it's an old field
it's been you know the set of things we
know now are built
on a tower that's been being constructed
for hundreds of years
and so a lot of the frontiers of
mathematics as they exist today
you need to climb that whole tower you
need to learn the whole series of levels
of of sort of uh of different kinds of
things that exist in mathematics
now what happens is every so often
people will invent
some new level of abstraction where you
say oh you don't need to learn
determinant theory you don't need to
learn the theory of invariance
you know determinant theory you just
learn linear algebra because linear
algebra
sort of covers all the detailed things
that were worked out in determinant
theory
you don't need to learn invariant theory
because that's all covered
by the theory of group representations
that sort of a more general theory
so that kind of thing can happen but
it's still a complicated tower of things
that you have to learn
i think what what happens in in in every
field
is when new methodology comes in you are
start to be able to do new things
that often don't that allow you
sometimes to make progress
without having climbed the whole tower
that exists
and the big thing in mathematics is
experimental mathematics
and the use of computation to to find
out what's true in mathematics
see most of mathematics as you would
learn it from
kind of the way that it's presented in
in academic journals and things
it looks like people do mathematics by
saying oh
there's the theorem we figured out is
true let's now give a proof of that
theorem
truth is many of the great
mathematicians euler gauss
many other people even riemann people
like that
they did experiments you know gauss
figured out the prime number theorem by
actually making a table of primes
and seeing that the density of primes
had some particular form
and then saying let me go try and do a
bunch of math to understand why it works
that way
this idea of experimental math where you
imagine some question
and you just do what today will be in
gauss's day it was
you know doing it by hand but today
would be use
you know use mathematically use welcome
language whatever to
to do you know to just do the
computation to find out what's true
that's a hugely powerful thing and it's
something where
it's been you know only the tiniest
tiniest corner of that has been explored
and what's really exciting about that is
you don't have to climb the whole tower
all the way up to sort of graduate
school mathematics to be able to make
contributions
when you ask the right questions doing
experimental mathematics
asking the right questions isn't always
easy um that requires
a sort of good conceptual understanding
of where sort of mathematics is going
what the structure of the field is
and so on to be able to ask questions
where
they're going to be interesting where
the answer is going to be interesting
sort of a famous example of this
revenue jan uh indian mathematician
around 1910-ish
time frame uh the um um
you know he was a very good hand
calculator
and um he came up with all these
incredible formulae
you know e to the uh uh pi
square root of 163 i think that's right
is almost exactly an integer he
discovered that
um the you know all kinds of weird
formulae like that
discovered by doing essentially his
version of experimental mathematics
but he had very good intuition about
what was worth looking at and that like
e to the pi square 163 i think that's
right
um is uh uh he's like
rather than just like oh that's a
coincidence he's like well actually that
tells you something very deep
about lots of things and in fact that
particular formula turns out to be
one of the main methods for computing
the digits of pi now
and it's deeply related to the theory of
elliptic functions and all kinds of
other things
ram lujan didn't work out all those
connections but he had a very good
intuition
for what were experiments that were
worth doing in effect
and in fact in his case it took decades
longer before people started filling in
and understanding how what he'd done
actually related to other areas of
mathematics but if you start from sort
of existing areas of mathematics
you say what can we now do by doing
computer experiments what can we now
discover
um that's something that is accessible
at sort of a a high school level
actually
and and the thing to understand is is
you know that
in doing research there's sort of two
pieces there's
there's what question you're going to
ask and how do you answer that question
and people a lot of the educational
process is about given a question
how are you going to answer it what the
education process usually
doesn't have in it is well what
questions should you ask
but in terms of success in research in
mathematics or other fields
it's actually the much more important
effect is what questions should you ask
and so kind of practicing the process of
ask a question wonder about something go
look at the distribution of of of uh
you know ternary primes or something go
see whether you can figure out why it
works that way
do the experiments see what's true i
think that's a really good driver
a modern driver that isn't what you
would find in and it's not what uh
your average kind of math professor is
going to tell you to do
because um because that's just not been
the practice of
mathematics as um uh as as it's been
done
um over the past uh particularly over
the past probably 50 years or so
but i think that the um that's a
fantastic opportunity and i've seen in
the course of the last 30 something
years since mathematica first existed
a bunch of people make wonderful careers
that have sort of been launched
by just doing experimental mathematics
in a bunch of different directions
and finding out a lot of things that are
true now you know one of the
one of the interesting meta points is if
you just do an arbitrary computational
experiment
and you get an answer sometimes those
those computational experiments
may be and you and you make some
hypothesis that seems to be true based
on
based on what you did there the question
is is that hypothesis something that is
at all reachable
by existing mathematics or is it
undecidable for existing mathematics is
the length of proof you need to give
essentially infinite what happens if you
just sort of drop in
arbitrarily asking a computational
question you can end up with these
questions that are
sort of infinitely far away from
existing mathematics but if you
inform your questions by things that are
already known in mathematics
that's a that's a good place to start
and i think you know the thing that is
really interesting to do at kind of a
high school level today
is you know go use mathematica basically
and go figure out a bunch of uh
you know just wonder about math try some
things out see what you think is true
see whether you can prove that that's
true maybe the proof is just i run it
and it does it
um but uh it's it's amazing when you
start to really open up and just think
about well what
what kind of mathematics question can
you ask
it's amazing how much you can find that
their questions just haven't been asked
i mean i was
looking at one recently it's it's one
that was kind of a
small thing in my book new kind of
science you know i was looking at
instead of fibonacci series so the
fibonacci series says
uh f of n is equal to f of n minus one
plus f of n minus two
um and you know you you started off with
f of one is one f of two is
is one and then you go it goes one one
two three five eight
et cetera et cetera et cetera um there's
a more complicated version of that
in which you have a sort of nested
fibonacci sequence
where you say f of n is f of
n minus f of n minus one instead of
f of n minus one it's the f of and the
argument of the f is
n minus f of n minus one those kinds of
things
uh if you uh you can you can rather
easily from that make these series that
which bounce around all over the place
and nobody knows anything about them and
that's a it's it's kind of amazing and
yet there's one actually that we found
um uh at our summer school when we first
did it in 2003
um uh that um particular series a bit
like that
generates prime numbers and it's like
how could this be that there's not
supposed to be a formula for primes
and actually a person who was at that
summer school who's now a math professor
um uh uh did a whole analysis of this
and figured out how it all works and
wrote paper about it and
and so on but that was something that
came out of just sort of doing the
experiment and then it turns out
to be an interesting piece of
mathematics so that's a few comments
about um
uh the aspiring mathematician thing
is um uh you know there's a there's a
place
experimental mathematics where you can
immediately jump into doing mathematics
research and get sort of feeling
for that process of inventing questions
and answering them and so on
all right i think that's uh we ran out
of time very much
for today uh thank you all for all those
great questions
and um look forward to seeing you again
next week
bye for now